thank you good afternoon everybody and
welcome to this meeting of the cabinet
we do have an additional item of urgent
business today but it's also a
confidential item so when we get to that
Ashley exclude the public not was that
many of them here we will allow the
members for suddely to come and stay for
that because it concerns them right
apologies for absence apologists receive
from counsel Pemberton right disclosures
of interest no right counsel Jefferson
right okay now if you put that on your
return to the monitoring office that
would not not need to declare every week
[Laughter]
okay but minutes minutes the meeting
held on the 11th of September which are
attached and have been circulated and
will published as a notice of decision
are you happy that sign those is a true
record agreed agreed thank you
item before will coat and paths flow
neighborhood plan pages 9 to 76 these
things of necessity take up a lot of
paper because of the what has to be
presented to us to make a decision and
the decision is that we accept the
recommended modifications in the
decision statement these modifications
are made following a report from an
independent examiner we've already made
one set of modifications when we had
considered this at cabinet earlier in
the year when we look at the officers
critique and then we get the we that we
then get the examiner's critique and
perhaps we ought to try and make certain
that the
examiners who take inaccurate say he
grab it all the love like one of the
same thing I think I can say that
because we haven't got anybody from
planning policy either so afternoon
anyway so basically we have a lot of
paperwork we have a version of the
Parrish neighborhood plan and that is as
a result of the modifications that are
listed in Appendix one now the officers
I haven't always recommend that the
modifications are agreed that's the
modification recommended by the
examiner's report sometimes
circumstances require a slight change
there have been a cases but not on
today's report will have accused the
examiner of getting it wrong and
therefore resisted the modification but
in these cases here the modifications
have been largely agreed that means that
it's in a fit state to go out to
referendum if we agree those
modifications and agree to send them to
a referendum it'll come back to us again
for adoption we'll come back to Council
for adoption by the Cabinet so
consequently without any more ado I'm
not going to go into details here we've
all seen it we've all had an opportunity
to read it we have a recommendation to
effectively send it off to
recommendation with those modifications
any comment discussion debate nope
so therefore I put the recommendations
on page nine to you and that's a great
thank you
right the next item will be on page 77 I
should think business rate discretionary
skin
that's counselor riches and he'll tell
us all about it Thank You chair
this item is to see cabinet approval to
spend funding that we're gonna receive
from central government to help local
businesses over the next four years a
uk-wide revaluation of all businesses
took effect in April 2017 at the time
there was quite some adverse media
coverage about it around 20% of
businesses in Stratford area we're not
and around 44% had a reduction the
government announced three changes of
spring budget to help with those
affected by the increase and I'll just
break those down quickly public house
relief pubs get a thousand pound off
their bill if they're new rateable value
is less than a hundred thousand one
hundred percent of this is funded by
central government effective from the
1st of April 2017 we've so far been
awarded 48 thousand pounds
small business relief this is designed
to ensure that no business pays more
than an increase of 600 pounds per year
100% funded by central government
effective the same funded for one year
of prison and then the discretionary
relief which we've got to agree our own
policy on as well it could Minister the
business rates for Stratford district
council we have agreed is similar we
have an agreed a similar scheme with
them being given a total of six hundred
eighty four thousand pounds to cover a
four-year period effective first of
April 2017 to get help a business must
have had a net rate increase of a
hundred pound or more and been in
occupation since the 1st of April no
awards properties with a rateable value
of less than one hundred thousand pounds
same as pub relief excludes
multinationals there are around 880
properties who might qualify for the
proposal and it is to award forty
percent of the rate increase in 2017
twenty percent in 2018 eight percent in
2019 and one percent in 2020 we required
year-on-year to spend all of the money
granted and this proposed this proposal
helps the maximum amount of businesses
by reducing their yearly business rates
over each of the next four years any
comments councillor Morse from my
reading of this I take it that we've
decided to grant local newspaper relief
automatically and then we're not
treating it as a discretion the item
that they apply they will get it thank
you for confirming that all the others
to talk about the public-house relief
chairman I'm sure there'll be many
pleased with that could I ask a question
on collectability Jenna I understand
that the government rules restrict the
maximum on council tax collection for
arrears to 385 pounds and that if you
haven't collected all your debt within
the two-year period anything over three
hundred and eighty-five pounds has to be
written off
dave is looking a bit a bit oh sorry mr.
Platts is pulling faces I'm more than
happy to take it outside of this meeting
but I wondered if there any similar
constraints on business rate relief but
shall I pick it up well not recently I
can answer the question certainly yes
there is an answer there might be there
isn't one I'd very much like to take it
offline if that's okay chair I'm not
aware of that at all it's complete news
to me so more than happy to discuss that
with councilor north outside the meeting
some councillors do feel that Liberal
Democrats confuse the public often being
confused chairman but this is apparently
based on legal advice issued and
magistrates by the professional society
for lawyers
yes thank you I take either you will
have amazing but perhaps you'll let us
know that outcome indeed yes thank you
right any sensible comments no so
basically we have a scheme and we have a
pot of money that the government
promised us some months ago to help
relieve the burden of increases now I
don't think councilor and breeches
mentioned the increases but with the
time mr. Platts did do me a very handy
briefing though which I'm left behind
but I do remember I gave my copy to the
Secretary of State right mmm who seemed
to appreciate it I think we had
something like 20 27 percent of business
ratepayers
actually had an increase you did did you
well I'd rather you took that rather
than pretend I wasn't listening however
so all those 27 percent of course some
people had enlarged their premises so
they deserve to pay more but on the
other hand we have a relief scheme and
indeed we have a methodology for carving
it up and I'm assured by mr. Platts that
he will not overspend and come running
back to us for a supplementary budget to
pay things and he's nodding in agreement
so basically we are asked to approve the
40 percent 20 percent 8 percent 1
percent which I was listening to and
therefore can we have an agreement
agreed agreed
he sure doesn't sound very positive it's
not our money it's the government's
money
right right moving on them well I can
find the right page 93 housing financial
assistant policy counselor reduced
richy's or Richard thank you shed and
remembers what you've got before you
today is a revised housing financial
assistance policy which is an update to
the existing policy of this council
since 2003 the council's had discretion
to develop and maintain such a policy
which provides financial assistance to
owners not revised of private sector
housing in the district when the
existing policy was drawn up it was done
so in consultation with Walsh County
Council and the five district and
Borough Council's which are known as
Hart with a home and environmental
assessment and response team
over time these policies have gradually
been revised and updated independently
and as a result we have a number of
different policies across all the
council's so this new policy has been
prepared by all five district and
Borough Council's for mutual adoption
and would provide consistent delivery
across at the Hart group it will also
align the aims and objectives of the
policy with those of the better care
fund a government supported fund the new
policy doesn't include any material
changes to the approach and forms of
assistance provided by this council
which include disabled facilities grants
discretionary disabled facilities grants
warm and safer home grants hospital
discharge grants and home and safety and
any person
grants and it also there are no there is
no change to the way in which this is
financed which is through the better
care fund so chairman it is a legal
requirement for us to hold to this
policy and I would recommend that the
cabinet approved this today please thank
you any queries or questions councillor
Morse
policy chair having a good day today on
German that's what you did sorry I
thought you're indicating to speak I'm
sorry Mike chairman these are quite
significant sums of money in fact the
current year nearly three quarters of a
million pounds of better care fund one
of the things that this can be spent on
is supporting and avoiding discharge
from acute care now I think we're all
aware of the problems of bed blocking
delayed discharge in hospitals and that
certainly applies in Warwick
I wonder if you tell me how much of this
money this year of Nastya has been spent
on helping to avoid - to help to avoid
bed blocking in our local hospitals and
I accept chairman it may may require a
delay before the answers given another
one to take offline a please yeah I
think we are gonna have to take that
offline I don't have that as a handle
unless anybody's got sir do you have any
information to add to that Rob chairman
I'll just be speculating so I think it's
wise that we take it offline and we give
the most accurate okay I will add one
thing since hearts been in existence and
we had a general policy document about
the payment of disabled facilities
grants that alone the little
supplementary lists that we've just
heard that has worked far more
efficiently than the service that
existed before were the five districts
work alone separately we did have an
interim Arrangements the north of the
county
south of the county and since the joint
countywide initiative has taken place
that was prompted because the government
decided to finance this through a thing
called the better care fund which they
financed despite the fact that the
county aren't a housing authority we are
they desire to give that funding to the
County Council which gave them an
opportunity to become involved so but
effectively I don't particularly want
them to take credit for the fact that
the service efficiency has improved
considerably but as you wish but the
thing is I'm gonna give them credit when
credits do doesn't seem to happen very
often but anyway the the issue is that
we had therefore a more effective
service and I would have thought that
would have minimized the risk of a bit
blocking but I can't quantify it and if
you want a constructive answer I think
Rob's suggestion and Peters suggestion
you take it offline is appropriate I'm
very happy to me feels your comment
about the improvement in the service
chairman right okay let's move on then
so okay hang on we're going to make a
decision to adopt the revised policy
right so the adoption policy
recommendation on page 93 is that agreed
thank you
we then come along to capital budget
monitoring page 101 counselor organ
Thank You chairman this report covers
the first five months of the year 1718
up to the 31st of August the total
capital budget for the year is four
million three hundred and six thousand
nine hundred and ninety eight capital
funding and progress on expenditure is
detailed in Appendix 1 and the section
106 funds that are held by the council
but not yet committed to projects are
detailed in appendix 2 and the
recommendation is that the position on
capital expenditure is received Thank
You chairman right any questions queries
nope right
so we receive the receive the report and
don't identify any issues of further
consideration so greed right revenue
budget monitoring counts are all them
thank you
this revenue report covers the same
period as the preceding capital report
and forecasts a favorable and term
variance for the year of one hundred and
thirteen thousand and thirty four pounds
this will undoubtedly a change before we
actually hit the errand details of the
main budget variances to date are
included within paragraph 3 of the
report and the details of the forecast
out term variances are in paragraph four
and again the recommendation is that the
report is received thank you okay
councillor Morse for the final time
chairman and I thought members would be
interested to note that earmarked and
revenue reserves are now expected to
exceed ten million pounds the Hanson
some of the council taxpayers money that
we're holding in our accounts
and I me I'm sure that the council
taxpayers are extremely grateful that we
are holding their money in our account
chairman I think we have some plans
suspended that we mr. Buckland the
Chairman taken the words out my mouth
obviously the medium term financial plan
that was approved in February would
we'll see those reserves we do
significantly over them up next five
years so they are planned to be utilized
we have had an under spend in 2016-17
that wasn't reflected in the medium term
financial plan that was approved by
council in February but when the budget
is revised that that underspend will be
carried forward and will be SS position
on reserves cancer oven Thank You
chairman I think it is somewhat ironic
that not so long ago councillor Morse
was complaining because the council was
spending too much of its capital and in
danger of not having any and now it
seems to be it is completely the reverse
situation that applies we didn't say we
aren't spending enough anyway
I'm also inclined to add the next Monday
afternoon in here
one of the afternoon's features will be
the strategic review report of which
councillor Morse was a member of the
group that's given rise to that and
indeed it starts off with a clear
forward medium-term plan which
identifies the reductions in the revenue
balances but they're likely to occur
should there be no action right okay so
we note that the academic exercise of
ten million yen right any other comments
or queries councillor Kinson where does
the Inc the benefit we have from the
dispersal of certain assets from that
and then you have a bonus is that credit
to capital or revenue Reserve
okay chairman I think the sale of the
carriages is was it's a capital C so
that was included in the previous
capital monitor meet Paul did he miss
new homes bonus as well that that that
is a financing item that helps the
council in financing the 13 million
pounds worth of expenditures that we've
got so the budget monitoring report we
get told what the new entrance is gonna
be for the year we don't have to monitor
that that that will be received it's
about three points it's not gonna suffer
for new services have been used to
support the overall revenue budget
position there we are
during 2008 1718 making the contribution
to reserves right
can I draw your attention counsel them
Tama page 113 it says here and this is
the out turn variance that means the
position that is likely to be in March
next year it says that shows a favorable
out turn balance of 33,000 which relates
to additional income being received in
respect of the recreation ground are we
letting out a lot more football pitches
or is this something to do with a
certain wheel as there disappeared um
neither chairman ah it is to do with a
sum that should have been accrued from
last year and wasn't accrued so when the
income came in because it hadn't been
accrued it had to show as additional
income right okay so we've got income
that we haven't approved so we're
showing but surely we don't have to
approve income to me I'll explain it
again this income should have been here
last year ah
and it didn't arrive last year its
arrival this year but because of a
failure to accrue it on the accounts it
has to be shown as additional volume but
if we didn't have it we couldn't show it
on the accounts good way okay thank you
for that I just didn't want us to
realize we'd have a difficulty without a
wheel okay any other query so it sounds
like that we're noting the or receiving
the variance at page 5 and the estimated
revenue at turn and we are not recording
any issues of further consideration so
agree read all right thank you
now that brings us to the end of the
main agenda no it's not I am dealt with
the on bloc items cabinet work program
alright
a strategic review group and the markets
forum as I haven't been asked to call
those out I'm just gonna ask you to note
those on block sell agreed and here's
your business
yeah chairman that's what ocean business
that you mentioned and start swimmin
right okay and that is a blue paper
urgent item which connects with Studley
so as someone got the wording of the
motion please ah thank you as it's not
on the agenda I'll move from the chair
pursuant to section 108 brackets for the
Local Government Act 1972 as amended the
public quite please the public be
excluded from the remaining businesses
are meeting in view of the fact the
nature of proceedings will be such but
if the public were presence there's
likely to be disclosure of them of
exempt information paragraph three parts
are the schedule 12a to the said Act
brackets as amended